I'm told that you are you seem like
you'd enjoy Disneyland you grew up near
there is that right well I grew up in
Ventura California and so we we would go
to Disneyland all the time and I love
Disney I love everything about Disney I
grew up in the 80s so we had the Disney
Channel and all the vaults and all the
cartoons and all that stuff it's it's
lovely so when you say you love Disney
it's not because since that time you
started working for Disney no and done
Disney movies no no there's one thing I
don't like about Disney tase know you
really do sincerely love Disney I do man
you go to Disneyland a lot right yes
yeah we go very often and honestly it's
you know it's it's helpful when you do
work for Disney and you know there's
some perks and things like that and I
get to bring my whole family down and
but you know and honestly it's like to
me even if you you know I've been on the
ride so many times and it's but it's
still like a great the ambience is
beautiful you just walk it's like a
beautiful park that how also happens to
have rides and weird pirates and some of
those rides and you know we'll get a
turkey leg which by the way I don't know
if you know this the turkey legs at
Disneyland I've come to find out are not
actually Turkey well they're they're a
big turkey legs there emu legs no
they're not Oh shocker rights hey if you
had one of the turkey legs
I haven't had I've seen them yeah you
walk around it's like a turkey leg in a
churro and it's like no I swear I I have
friends that have worked for Disneyland
and and I was talking about how the
turkey legs tasted more like ham then
they taste like Turkey which was already
befuddling and they said well they're
actually EMU there's a big big old EMU
legs got a turkey leg at Disneyland
you've eaten a few folks I used this is
sound like an urban myth are you sure
they're really it would explain all the
emus I've seen in wheelchair is a Disney
hey we get to the from the lines though
God's sake no seriously you're saying
first of all you're supposed to be the
guy that's Pro Disney they're gonna be
thrilled with you cracking the big case
that it's cool eggs this is more of an
emu do we have a picture of any there it
is okay why did you do it why'd you take
my legs cuz they're tasty so do you
think that's true you really think it's
true I don't know I mean this is what I
heard on very good authority from former
employees of Disneyland you thought you
knew throwing shade yes why not I'm
still working for Disney
I hope not anymore right now exec is
watching he's sure I hear and order me
some more EMU legs
this is a cat it's stroking or a legless
email that is a crazy thing that you're
spreading around I hope it's true I hope
so too
yeah think of my reputation on this
interview yeah yeah no no you're done
with them
[Laughter]
you